you're gonna make 70 000 in commission
on friday yes
focus on may king money
people say to me they say samuel you
know um you must have just got in at the
right time
you know i bought my first property in
2009
and in 2009 i'll tell you what was
happening excuse me
well we probably know we probably know
so 2008
banks started started saying
they were running out of money they
couldn't lend any more money
and property houses started to go down
in fact they didn't start to go down
they crashed
2009 properties were absolutely crashing
everyone was devastated everyone was
pulling their hair out saying
the days of property investing
are over
that was when i got started now bear in
mind
i'm a teenager at the time actually i'm
17
i'm 17 years old now i'm 29 by the way
i'll be i'll be 30 in a couple months
but at the time i'm i'm 20 i'm 20 i'm
sorry i'm 17.
i've got no money
any money that i did have from
paper rounds and stuff while i was at
school
i invested on training and everyone was
saying to me
some people were saying you're crazy
why are you spending three thousand
pounds
on on on training about property and
what are you doing said the person that
was going to university
to study drama right like that's okay
that's okay oh you want to go to
university
and spend 9 000 pounds per semester to
study art
congratulations good for you you want to
spend
you want to spend 3 000 learning about
economics and property investing and
wealth and financial literacy and
independence
oh that's risky man that's risky people
are crazy
and i've been saying this for years but
only now people are actually beginning
to realize it
i've been saying this for years so i had
no money
it's 2009 i'm 17 years old
no money but i have got a little bit of
knowledge
and and i've i'm learning how to buy
properties
and then we finance them the same day
buy them below market value then
finance them i'm learning all the
creative strategies
but i'm 17 i've got no money i'm from a
working class background
my parents haven't given me or can't
give me any money
my i failed pretty much in school i got
some gcses i got three gcses that was it
so and and we're in the middle of
not even the middle we're at the
beginning of a massive
recession so do you reckon by thumbs up
or thumbs down
do you reckon most people would see me
in a good position ready to prosper
thumbs up or thumbs down
thumbs down now here's the really
exciting thing
fast forward 12 years okay
obviously i did well in property in fact
what what people don't realize is
when everybody's scared as warren
buffett says that's when you should be
greedy and when everybody's greedy
that's when you should be scared when
the taxi drivers are talking about
bitcoin
oh the taxi drivers that's when i'm like
i'm out
when people are like oh man uh about
something that's really cool it could be
interesting so so at this point
you know i'm being told by everybody be
careful
be careful you know now is a bad time
the media are saying it's a bad time all
the mainstream newspapers or robert
kiyosaki calls it lame stream
newspapers you know they're all saying
bye till that's dead
everything's dead and and that's when i
got in and let me tell you something
that's really exciting
not only did i win of course i of course
i won because that's the time to make
money but the exciting thing is
fast forward 12 years we're in exactly
the same situation again
joshua what's been happening yeah we're
good i'm good
we've just got two went to well rent to
us and i rented hmo over the line
we're picking up the keys for them this
friday for an investor
we've just got just got a testimonial
off him as well that i'm going to be
putting out later
we've got free serviced accommodations
in liverpool at the moment
for right on albert docks they're
absolutely gorgeous we've just i
messaged you the other day about it
yeah um so we're just going through
sorting that we're going to have to do
that as a corporate left but the
management company that we use
she'll have that field for six months
for us for the investor that takes them
on
and then we've just taken on another
investor today for bespoke sourcing
hey that's fabulous
so yeah all of it though it's
everything's from your training brother
like literally everything so it started
off with your free training
on youtube like the amount you can do
with just your free training alone
is unreal so uh where we are now in
property and what we're doing we owe a
lot of it to you
but i wouldn't be in poverty now and
know the things that if it weren't for
you
it's so funny because annalisa and damon
and me were just talking about this
yesterday
how funny is it that we only met a
couple of months ago and now we're doing
business together and we're friends and
it's all going so naturally
it's amazing yeah and also alexandra
um am i right in thinking that you've
got two rent service departments but
you've just secured another two
yeah and now as well
for anyone that doesn't know anyone that
missed it last week
um alexandra as well has just quit her
job
he's now full time in property
so again massive congratulations
alexandra
what would you say to somebody that was
struggling getting that first deal
overnight because the first deal was
always the hardest
what advice would you give to someone
that's just struggling to get that first
deal
to have really good energy to keep
talking to people because that's what
matters the most i wouldn't be here if i
didn't keep talking to people i network
a lot i'm very curious to find out their
story how they work what they do to
succeed
that's what keeping me going yeah and
did you notice
energy energy yeah energy is very
important
high energy big energy equals big
bank accounts yeah
too much i mean it's all coming so i got
the second viewing tomorrow for a
property
in london it's a big house to 16 baggage
motor transfer of an apartment so the
fee is 14 000
where we're still waiting if they accept
the offer okay
um and then there is another one
the completion comes on friday so i get
0.5 percent i think i told wednesday to
anthony
or 3.5 million i'm gonna get that on
friday 12 o'clock
20 000. uh 70
500 right you're going to make 70 000
in commission on friday yeah i already
got in advance of 4 000
but yeah the total is 70 000 holy moly
when you like delivering pizzas or
something when you first dress up
delivering boxes for her miss this is
when i lost my job
and then yeah as i was doing that seven
days a week
and like and looking for these investors
at nighttime like you said
i don't know what to say man i'm just so
i i
was going to succeed when graziella
joined the academy
like only a month or so back i drove
around her house
just to congratulate her i literally
drove to her house
knocked the door and she opened it she
was like oh what are you doing now i
said
i've just come to say congratulations
for joining the academy like that's it
i just knew that she was an absolute
diamond obviously i don't always do that
um
but i just felt like it that one even
and graziella that's incredible please
let us know
no one cares like
no one knows the name of my company
chris
is chris said chris said i'm a hardcore
follower and fan of you samuels i said
what wasn't that my company
um and then he said i don't know he said
because i follow you not your company
people buy from people they don't care
what your logo looks like
they don't care whether you've got the
correct sick code on your freaking
company people
oh what's what's the zip code most
companies have got a wrong sit code and
guess what
no one cares
so just focus on one thing and what's
that
focus on may king money
if you need to tell me next week samuel
i've had a great week i've just i've
just registered my company guess what
i'll say i'll say
i'm not interested saying i've had a
really good week i've got my logo
designed i'll say congratulations but
i'm not interested you tell me sam i've
had a great week i just made 70 000
pounds on the deal
i said great graciela what's the name of
your company
but i think everyone just know me knows
me like graciela
okay so your name is minitron properties
guess what no one cares
no one even knew that i didn't know that
it's a rubbish name
it's so unoriginal but you still made
70 grand this week
how many of you are getting the memo
[Music]
you